the world has has changed so much in the
last 10 years
this is very beautifully brought out
enough Philip Roth novel called called
exit ghost where Roth's Alta ego who has
been living in the country comes back
into New York City in 2004 and he finds
that everyone is on iPods is on cell
phones and and and and that society is
he knew it the human interaction has
more or less disappeared that everyone
is engrossed you know in these things
which are almost analogous to
hallucinations they're here in music
they're hearing voices they're talking
the two things about iPods or three
things listen first
I haven't iPod myself I I have all bar
on my iPod
I have the equivalent of 157 CDs on my
ipod and as a bath lover
I'm as fantastic privileged to have all
bark in something the size of a matchbox
however I don't listen to it in the
street I don't listen to it when I'm
driving the car I don't listen to it
when I ride my bicycle because I need my
attention for reality I'm frightened at
the degree of engrossment which people
can have with iPods and I I think they
should all move offers be forbidden to
cyclists and pedestrians I also wonder
whether to separate music from context I
mean music arose in a communal way
people would sing together dance
together there would be concerts there
would be churches there would be living
performance and I think I think music
can become too abstract and - divorced
from content
if one only listens to an iPod i it's
wonderful that ipods can give so much
but i'm also concerned that they may
take people away from musical
environments in contexts in which they
should have music so I'm a little
worried about the the isolating and
abstracting and also dangerously
engrossing qualities and iPods